this video is part of my clean code in
JavaScript series this video is all
about solid solid is an acronym that
stands for five basic principles of
object-oriented programming and design
the s in solid stands for single
responsibility principle this principle
states that everything should only have
one reason to change this will help
developers understand the context and
responsibilities of what they're
building and when there is a need for
change so here is the bad way to do it
in the user settings we have a change
settings function and we have a verify
credentials function now this is really
two different things there's the
settings and there's the credentials so
this is not this is just a single
responsibility if you go down here we
have the good way to do it
the good way to do it we're gonna have
two different classes we're gonna have
the user off class and the user settings
class and so one of them is responsible
for verifying credentials and the other
one is responsible for change settings
so that represents in solid stands for
the open closed principle now this
appears actually the bad way to do it
first let me explain the principle
software entities should be open for
extension but closed for modification
this basically means that if someone
wants to extend our modules behavior
they won't need to modify existing code
if they don't want to there's an easy
rule of thumb if you have to open the
JavaScript file of your module and make
the modification in order to extend it
you have failed the open closed
principle so let's see in this example
here we're making an ice cream maker we
have ice cream flavors chocolate of
vanilla and then we're creating this ice
cream maker with the make ice cream
function where you pass in the flavor
and it's going to either say great
success you know ice cream or epic fail
no ice cream for you depending on if you
if the flavor you pass in is in the ice
cream flavors array so if you pass them
chocolate to make the ice cream it's
going to say great success know you have
ice cream then if it's not an array
you're gonna have effort fail no ice
cream for you now the problem with this
is that there is no way to add
ice-cream flavor without editing the ice
cream flavor array so we can easily
change that here's the good way to do it
we've just added this extra function
here which is to add a flavor and it's
going to do ice cream flavors that push
flavor so you can add maybe strawberry
here or something like that and then you
can now make ice cream in the strawberry
flavor so and the bad way to do it we
would have had to go into the file and
actually add the strawberry flavor to
the array here we don't have to do that
we can just use the method of the
function to change that array so we
don't have to modify the existing code
to extend the behavior
okay the L in solid stands for the
Liskov substitution principle this means
that derived objects or types must be
substitutable for their base again this
will make more sense with an example
this is the bad way to do it we have a
class we have a rectangle class and it's
going to have a constructor with the
width and height where you're gonna be
able to besides setting the color and
the rendering you're gonna set the width
to the width that you passed in you're
gonna set the height to the height that
you passed in and we can also get area
now we can create a square which goal is
going to extend a rectangle on all
squares or rectangles but not all
rectangles or squares so here we're only
at and we're going only going to
overwrite two functions which is the set
width and set height and C we're gonna
set width the width and height to the
width they passed in and if you do set
height they're gonna set the height to
the height the width and height they're
gonna be set to that height you passed
in the square and here it's from the
rectangle class according to the Liskov
substitution principle you should be
able to substitute the square class for
anytime you would normally use the
rectangle class and your code should
function as expected but you will see in
this bad example it doesn't work out
that way so if you see this part here
we're gonna create these red rectangles
to be a new rectangle new rectangle new
square and then we're going to render
the large rectangle
and pass on this rectangle array so it's
gonna call this function and for each
rectangle in that array it's going to
set the width for then it's gonna accept
a height of five and it's gonna get the
area of that rectangle it would actually
return 25 for square because the height
we passed was five and it basically just
over wrote the width so this would work
for rectangles when the width and height
that are different but it's not gonna
work for squares so you can't really
substitute square them for rectangles
and it behaved how you would want it to
behave so here's the good way to do it
we're gonna create a shape class it has
the set color and the render that are
going to be the same for any to any
shape then we're gonna have the
rectangle class which has the
constructor the width and height and
it's going to set the width and height
and you can get the area by multiplying
the width times the height and now if
you look at the square class this is
going to extend the shape it's not even
going to extend rectangle it's going to
extend the shape class and within the
constructor we are just going to pass in
a length and then you guys set the
length and the area is length times
length now up here we had the render
large rectangles function but down here
we have the render large shapes the
rectangle and square both extend from
shape and the square did not extend from
rectangle so we're gonna create the new
rectangle by passing in the four and
five because if you'd see here the
rectangle you passed and width and
height and the square you're just going
to pass in the length so you're gonna
create them differently pass in form
five for rectangle for new reptil you'll
pass on four or five but two new square
just going to pass in five and then
you're still going to be able to render
large shapes and pass in the shapes
array and shapes at for each shape
you're gonna get the area since the
rectangle class forget area is returned
this that width times the height and the
square has returned this that length
times this dot length it's going to
behave how you expected so you are in
fact able to substitute squares and
rectangles and you're going to get what
you would expect so this goes along with
the Liskov substitution principle
the iron solid stands for interface
segregation principle a client should
not be forced to depend on interfaces it
doesn't use now javascript doesn't have
interfaces so this principle doesn't
apply strictly as others but a good
example look at that demonstrates this
principle in JavaScript is for classes
that require large settings objects not
requiring clients to set up huge amounts
of options it's beneficial because most
of the time they won't need all the
settings so let's look at the bad way to
do it just right here recurring a Dom
traverser class and we're gonna pass in
some settings so we're gonna put all the
settings in the here now if you see here
it's going to run the setup function and
it's going to get the root node which
we're always going to want but the point
of this bad example is that you may not
always want the animation module so in
this bad example you always have to pass
in a root node and you always have to
pass in the animation module because in
the setup it's going to access the
animation module dot setup but we may
not need to animate so in the good way
to do it we're going to make passing in
the animation module optional so it's
pretty similar but we are going to have
the root node and when we're creating
the Dom traverser we're also going to
have options and anything in this
options object is optional but we're
going to set the options to the settings
the options that we passed in from here
and here we're always going to set the
root node to sense that root node and
then we're going to call the setup
options function down here and now here
it's if this the options are enemy
module so if we passed in the anime's
module then we're gonna run the setup
for that but if we didn't pass it in
we're not gonna run the setup so it's
optional whether you pass in these
options or not and the last part of the
solid the d stands for dependency
inversion principle now this is another
principle best explained by example but
let me tell you the definition first
this principle states two essential
things one high-level modules should not
depend on
low level modules both to depend on
abstractions in to abstractions should
not depend upon details details should
depend on abstractions this is all about
handing over control from the function
itself to the color of the function so
let's look at the the bad way to do this
so in the bad way we're gonna create
this inventory tracker class and it's
always going to use the inventory
requester class so you have no choice to
use the inventory requester class and
the good way to do it we are going to be
able to choose which inventory requests
are we use so here when we create this
inventory tracker we're going to treat
the new inventory tracker which is this
and we're going to pass in these
inventory items here it's going to sign
the items to the items and then we're
going to set the requester to a new
inventory requester up here and this
inventory requester is always going to
use the HTTP method so when we do
inventory tracker that request items
it's going to use the requester we set
up here which is the inventory requester
to request items and it's going to
request the items using HTTP now we may
not always want to use HTTP so instead
of always depending on this inventory
requester class we want to give give
ourselves more options so here's a good
way to do it we're still going to have
the inventory tractor but instead of
just passing in items to the inventory
tracker because we're up here we only
test in items now we're going to pass in
items and we're going to pass them the
requester so remember before the
requester was always the same but now we
are going to be able to pass in a
different requester so there's two types
of requesters we have requests are
version 1 and requester version two
requests a version 1 is going to use
HTTP request their version 2 is going to
use WebSockets so we can now use the
inventory tracker class for both HTTP
and web
we just pass in a different requester
and it's going to set this that
requester to whatever request we pass in
and then when we request items it's
going to either use the HTTP request or
the WebSocket requests or to request the
items so if you look down here now when
we create the inventory tracker we're
going to create a new inventory tracker
we're gonna pass in the items and then
we are going to pass an either the new
inventory request or version 2 which is
the WebSockets one or the version 1 this
is going to allow us to easily
substitute the request module and just
make it easier to refactor and make it
easier to use the inventory tracker a
class for different purposes well thanks
again to Ryan McDermott who wrote the
article that inspired this series many
of the code examples come from his
article check the description of this
video for a link to his original article
and thank you for watching my name is
beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good